quelques minutes seulement après le top
départ un trio fait très vite la course
en tête l'éthiopien torah combi béchir
et le tourangeau yosi goasdoué et
langevin mathieu bosquet
20 km plus tard bosquet est distancé par
béchir et goasdoué sur les bords de
loire mais cinq kilomètres plus loin il
rattrape son retard quinze ans que
mathieu bousquet n'avait plus participé
à un marathon je reviens 23e donc le
mental est relancé sur des crochets au
32e et là je me dis toute façon je peux
pas aller aussi vite que yvon ce qu'ils
visaient une accélération donc je vais à
mon rythme
et puis on verra ce qui se passe
au village de saint genou derrière
béchir hayoz yves goasdoué commence à
fatiguer le tourangeau est plutôt un
habitué des semi marathons il en a été
champion de france en 2015
c'est relativement simple jusqu'au 30e
après c'est plus compliqué mais qui nous
le challenge que je m'étais dit allez on
va essayer d'aller d'aller voir c'est si
on peut titiller le premier jeu j'ai
suivi jusqu'au 35e après
après je me rappelle que beaucoup
pointent à six kilomètres du sprint
final c'est toujours le maillot rouge et
bleu qui mène la course l'éthiopien de
40 ans franchit le premier la ligne
d'arrivée
[Musique]
le marathon de tours un simple
entraînement pour cet habitué des
courses à pied
à l'école personnel c'est 2h14
c'est 2 à 14 c l'îlot made in 2011 s'est
longtemps aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
tranquille je sais pas c'est comme
regarder de 0.30 voilà c'est sera-t-elle
pour ma douce et tranquille poitiers
toulouse ou encore nantes sont les
prochains objectifs du vainqueur tours a
combiné chez